We must reject,
I would say fundamentally the idea of
those deportations to torture it doesn't
work.
It undermines the very values that we
are fighting to defend.
It undermines democracy,
the rule of law and basic human rights
and human rights,
all the only universal language of
mankind that transcends national
identity that transcends religious and
cultural differences.
If we start losing them,
we have no language and they're basic
principles,
the to talk to other people in other
cultures and other nations in other
racial groups for if we started
abandoning them and then they'll say,
you've got no moral authority at all to
preach to us,
to talk to us or to tell us.
So I asked you to vote for justice.
I asked you to vote for reason.
I asked you to vote against rough
justice,
vote with our House of Lords in
rejecting Belmarsh vote with our mps in
rejecting the 90 days and say no to
rough justice.
Thank you.